is because the sort of woman that would
go on your show is a very specific do
you think so because i i interview women
on the street all the time like i it's
random half the girls come that come on
my show don't even know what show
they're coming on yeah so it's like it's
very random but that's i think that's
the point i'm making the fact that they
would say yes to it because i know a lot
of women who
just wouldn't say yes to it just because
they don't want to be out there they
don't want to be on social life yeah and
so they just wouldn't okay they wouldn't
say yes
but you would agree that the general
trend that women are [ __ ] now than
they were of course i definitely agree
50 if you had two partners you were
i think the average man prays for two i
don't
i definitely agree that obviously you
know yeah people are becoming more
promiscuous yeah you know but then don't
you think that
do you think that the current red pool
message is helping that
um i think it's waking like okay
so you have the top 20 percent of guys
let's let's say 20. some red pill guys
would argue five percent of guys someone
argued 10 let's say 20 are screwing all
the girls and the next like 30 percent
of the guys that get them after they get
the leftovers that's why they say
leftover women and so a lot of guys are
marrying a girl thinking that they're
that girl's first choice because they're
marrying her but really like she wants
the guys that she slept with in her 20s
and so i think it's important for guys
to understand
that
if you if you date a more promiscuous
woman
it's more likely that she's going to
leave because she only wanted you for
the kids and the resources but see this
is this is a point where i have somewhat
a bit of contention because
we always say that
if a man marries a woman he's being
promiscuous then she's more likely to
leave but then we've also
the same stats will also show that if a
man has a higher body count he's also
more likely to be uh less sexually
satisfied and so that could lead to him
stepping up not necessarily because at
like three to four um he actually has a
higher marriage satisfaction at seven to
eight partners than he does at three to
four
so but you're right the the i mean i
always say like if you can get two
virgins that's the ideal that's the
happiest marriage
but um it the the point is that
promiscuity affects
women more than men
and modern societies
well so the average um women that sleep
with five or more partners have less
than a 30 percent chance of a happy
marriage after 10 years where a virgin
has an 80 chance you don't see that
level of drop off among men you don't
have any
most red pill channels wouldn't
disagree with that i mean i don't
necessarily
prescribe like the
f you know 30 before you like i don't i
don't tell people to sleep around yeah i
say this is the information do what you
want with it and the point is if a guy
sleeps with four partners and a guy
sleeps with eight partners so double
that he's more happy in his marriage at
eight
i don't know why
but the thing is i will say yeah that is
part of our do you like your channel i
do make you on channel so much because
you don't tend to just necessarily
push people towards that lifestyle you
also just state the facts and state yeah
but i will say a lot i think a lot of
the more
of the current mainstream red bull
content does push that lifestyle does
encourage it and does that's true i say
that and that tends to be a place where
i have a problem
with them because
you know they're saying they want to
help men right which i don't this i
don't
doubt that that's where they that's what
they want to do however they're not
actually telling them in lifestyles that
would actually most likely make them um
be happier in a relationship why why do
they tell them that
i don't know
does marriage benefit the average man
today
it depends on what you mean exactly
is it beneficial for the average man to
get married
does the does the benefit outweigh the
risk
again it depends what you mean because
stats will show you that you know a man
who's married um actually
[Music]
is less is less likely to be depressed
is less likely to
feel isolated is more likely to what's
it called to recover from certain
diseases and when when it was more like
a better healthcare when it will you
know so i i think there are certain
benefits that come with getting married
correct correct but but your key key
phrases is
is married yeah 50 divorce rate yeah so
you have a 50 50 shot and if she leaves
you to take half your stuff and your
kids
that makes it especially especially in
the u.s where a lot of these red pill
channels are based like um so if you're
there's a guy in california whose wife
left him took the kid with her and went
to japan yeah and you said did you see
that video that's messed up like that's
the level of risk that men
are facing and so
it's like if if if we're making men
have this level of responsibility like
why would you get married i wouldn't if
i lived in california if i was a dude
and she could take a quarter per kid 25
of my after tax income
that
and if you lose your job and you can't
pay it you go to jail oh no see i
understand
the argument
i understand that argument yeah right
but then the whole point of the red bull
movement is to push men to do better and
to increase a lot a lot of things they
say is to increase your your income
right yeah so it turns out that marriage
is especially in the u.s um once you get
to a 250k threshold and above marriage
divorces go down to plummet to 20
percent
so i think it's 25 now i thought about
it
but
still one out of four chants you can
take
like i'm just saying that's that's
that's crazy like and the point is if
men start walking away from that maybe
the laws will change but i don't
understand why the government needs to
be involved in marriage to be you know
for me the way i see it i think if you
want to get married someone you don't
necessarily have to you know there are
some tax benefits that people get from
you know from being actually married so
if you want those then do that
however i think to
to say to push a narrative that there's
no benefit to a man being married to men
to be married it's just it's just wrong
i don't know especially when we tell
when they tell people that a high value
man the only reason why they want to
marry a woman is to it's for their
legacy and their children right well i
don't that's why i don't i don't tell
people not to get married but i
understand why they don't yeah and like
i perfectly understand why they tell me
not not to get married when the laws are
the way they are
that's that's like my view on it i think
people are free to choose of course if
that's the risk you want to weigh
but if i lived in california and that
was oh god
cooked cooked
i'm not gonna laughing if you lived in
california like genuinely not you make
you go let's say you get the 250 000 a
year and now you know there's a one in
four chance that you get divorced and
she's she can take your kids to another
country and take half your [ __ ] yeah
i mean don't get me wrong i think
especially you wouldn't understand why
those guys see you know you know what
i'm gonna just [ __ ] a bunch of [ __ ]
i think especially in america is yeah
it's especially bad over there it's not
as bad here is it i mean it's still
thirteen percent yeah they're still bad
income and they can still seize your
assets you know as i said it's still bad
but i think america's
it's another level of just
wow okay but yeah i do think you know
when you're saying when you're saying
the high value man the only reason why
they want to get married to these modern
women is you know their kids right
i wouldn't i don't know not you you yeah
yeah the red pool message in general
tends to be that like not necessarily if
you do rollo like he's you know some
would say the godfather of the regime he
doesn't tell people what to do he always
says it's a praxeology not an ideology
he doesn't he doesn't really give advice
he just says he says these are these are
the stats to do with it what you want my
problem with role is that he is living a
life
which he seems to be relatively happy in
but then he doesn't exactly tell people
um
he doesn't exactly tell people what he's
done to be happy and or he doesn't
necessarily prescribe what he does talk
about what he did if you if you watch
more of it so i've watched his concert
yeah and even he had a debate with
because he has like his rockstar 20.
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he had this
debate with uh rustling i think he i
think i don't know who that is
it's just another youtuber um and he
basically said himself he doesn't
prescribe he just tells people how it is
he said that word for what
but the problem is is that
in a sense his people go to his whether
he does
people go to his books because they want
to learn um they want to learn certain
things but what he's trying to say is he
has given you the tools and do it do
what you want with the tools well he
doesn't give you a twizzler because i
would say he does so like i think his
his chart about women is actually very
accurate
so like you know when girls around like
29 to 35 are looking for more of a
provider type i think that's really good
to know for men
that you know she's probably just
looking at for you for your resources
that's good to know
it's good to know what an alpha widow is
could you explain that for people who
don't you've explained it it's like an
alpha widow's basically i'll give you a
story that goes with it and alpha widow
is basically like a girl that can't get
over her ex like